Shadow business secretary Jonathan
Reynolds with us now we can't afford
these pay Rises that the unions are
asking for well let's unpack this a
little bit now when ministers say they
can't afford it there's a little bit of
Truth in that because the economy hasn't
done very well for 12 years under them
and so any resources we've got to spend
on public services are diminished on
what they should be so like what they
should add to their sentences there is
if we can't afford it it's their fault
to do so however there are things
government can do what I worry listening
to those collection of cabinet ministers
there is
they think they've got an opportunity
here to deflect from the fact that they
haven't run the economy in public
services very well and they can somehow
blame working people or unions by
highlighting the strikes as the strikes
of the symptom of how badly they have
run things and particularly on the NHS
you know everyone should recognize the
pay issue is also about workload and
burden on AHS staff and there are things
the government could do they could for
instance take our plan which is a future
labor government would have abandon the
the non-dom rule the special uh tax
regime for the super everything well but
it would pay in this case what we would
use the money for for a significant
expansion of the NHS Workforce in terms
of more doctors more District Health
visitors more midwives more nurses that
would help a great deal and I think you
just if you're a government Minister
you've got to roll up your sleeves and
try and resolve these disputes nobody
nobody wants to take industrial action
they don't want to lose the money but
they also don't want to see the impact
on the public but if the government
won't listen to them what option of
people got but to try and make
themselves heard by taking that action
so there are things the government doing
it's not good enough to come on and just
be passive and say look we're somehow
commentating on this they've got to get
involved and resolve these disputes so
you'd use the non-dom money um for um
pay uh in the National Health Service
and others what about the Eco plans that
you have got to make us all a little bit
Greener at home how would you pay for
that well those plans are about
investment spending so where we would
increase Revenue spending for instance
on the on the NHS we will always
identify the results it will all
government spending Capital spending is
borrowing and the question is is the
return you get for doing that greater
than the cost of of investing so I think
the case on climate change is absolutely
clear that the costs of not doing
anything are far more extensive than
taking action but crucially what you get
with our plans our ability to get the
green jobs of the future the good
skilled work that's available whether
that's in new nuclear or new Renewables
or Energy Efficiency measures in
people's homes and get the benefit of
that this could be for the UK the
biggest Economic Opportunity for many
many years and we don't want to be
following the rest of we want to be
leading we want to be a clean energy
superpower exporting that power
exporting the technology and The
Innovation that we've got in the UK but
the government's got a lead on that and
so you would borrow more than the
government's is planning sparrower than
if you were in power well
this government borrows money for
instance to pay for tax Goods
the test of borrowing is about whether
you're investing it and you'll get a
greater return from investing it than
you would from not taking that action
now I don't think anyone can seriously
say we shouldn't respond to Net Zero we
shouldn't for instance make sure that we
are in line with our International
commitments but what we want to do is
get the maximum economic benefit for the
UK of doing that so give me one specific
example you know this country has about
three quarters of a million people
working in the automotive industry so
it's a jewel in the crown of our
industrial base if we do not invest to
make sure we've got battery production
for electric vehicles in the UK we won't
just filter seize that opportunity we'll
lose those existing jobs and that
requires the government investing a
little bit of money to make sure there's
a greater amount of private investment
coming in that's how other countries are
doing that's why Germany is so far ahead
of the UK for instance so it's about
making sure you're you're clearly
identifying the opportunities and if you
need to invest some government money to
do that customer is greater yes but it's
not about borrowing more money for
day-to-day spending that's where this
government went wrong and what should we
do about onshore wind farms just to
underline I think labor are in favor of
more
um but we're hearing that it's it's an
issue that is splitting this government
some of them are a little bit NIMBY and
some of them are saying no no it's what
we need what would you say to the
government this morning well we've been
making the case for quite a few years
now since they had the de facto ban an
onshore wind and it makes no sense to
ban the cheapest form of energy
production I mean as it stands light on
the landscape says David Davis well that
isn't what the public see this as every
single pool shows that actually a lot of
conservative and bees are out of step
with the public on this but to have a
position where you completely ban the
cheapest form of energy production even
if people are very much in favor in area
or if it's a particularly appropriate
thing I actually think winforms look
very attractive I'm used to seeing them
on the landscape they make a quite a
wonderful contribution to that but most
of all if you look at how much how much
damage has been done by this energy
crisis where you know the price of
fossil fuels has absolutely spiked the
idea you don't try and reduce your
dependency on that volatility you don't
see the opportunity you don't use safe
secure clean forms of energy in the UK
how can that make sense and as ever what
we see with this government is no matter
what the prime minister or any
government ministers might come on and
say every issue is determined by the
internal politics of the conservative
party by the divisions they've got and
it's just nowhere to run a country
should we be sending um albanians who
are seeking Asylum back the moment that
they've stepped foot on British soil
look where we have a legal entry into
the UK what we've got to have is a
system that resolves those claims
on the time scale that people quite
rightly expect and which we need I think
we've got the worst of all Worlds at the
minute where people who are who should
be being granted asylum in the UK aren't
getting an answer clearly enough and
people who should be removed aren't me
being removed enough but if you've only
got a process I think this government's
two percent of the claims that were made
last year it doesn't matter what else
you do the system isn't going to work
they should take the money they're
wasting on gimmicks like Rwanda and
spend it on processing these claims
having the capacity we need and
everything else I think it's just froth
okay does that is does labor think that
Albania is a safe country
I think it's not helpful to single out
particular countries about Albania do
you think it's the same organized
criminality issues about certain
countries but I think what we've got to
acknowledge is the system as well
doesn't matter what country people are
coming from
you cannot have a system that simply
doesn't get to the bottom of whether
claims should be upheld or not and but
if it's a safe country they shouldn't be
coming from there I mean that's what the
same confusion because okay so is
Albania a safe country I think Albania
is a safe country though they shouldn't
be here so they should be said that well
I think look again focusing on you know
David the government are attempting to
try and put this on particular countries
rather than accept their own failings
that the system isn't working as it
should do so our focus should be on
demanding of this government an
efficient Fair system with the capacity
it needs to resolve these claims and and
that's nothing else will do unless the
government acknowledges their own
failings on that key issue